here's the one two from moscow and a
swing and a miss he struck him out he
went upstairs with a fastball
and the young is the first strikeout
victim for muskrobe for up and four down
three and two with tyler o'neill
on deck
got him looking what a pitch there
beauty guillermo heredia
seventh place hitter leads things off
and strikes out in the first strikeout
of 2020 for jack flaherty on a nasty
pitch there a good curve ball right here
from jack it just stays on top of this
thing
bottom falls out of it
three and two on jacob stallings and a
strikeout for flaherty back-to-back case
to start this inning
and what a start to this season that is
eight up and eight down for jack
flaherty tyler o'neil
batted 262 with five home runs last year
he hit six doubles
and o'neal lifts it in the air out to
left center it's at the wall gone
home run tyler o'neal in his first bet
of 2020 takes it deep into the bullpen a
breaking ball that backs up on tyler
o'neill a little bit does a great job of
staying back keeping his hands in
and just lets the raw power take over i
love seeing a start like that for him
the batter is colin moran with runners
now at first and second and two outs
nothing in two of the count flaherty
to colin moran swing and a miss he
struck him out and the pirates will
strand a pair he was able to get osuna
to reach
on a curve ball his last at-bat we'll
see how he goes after him here 3-2
fastball and he struck him out
95 on the gun and flaherty
picks up strikeout number four
herreria the right fielder struck out on
a curveball that's lined into the glove
of third baseman tommy edmond for out
number two
here's dexter fowler second time that he
has been up and the one-two
and fowler hits a fly ball out to deep
right at the wall it is gone
home run dexter fowler
fowler on a one-two pitch drives it out
to right and it's two to nothing st
louis
dexter anything
middle in
he can turn and burn on that hit 434 on
fastball's end last year got one there
and drove it then it brings in colt long
lead off hitter and the one two
wong sends one into the gap in right
center this ball is down
all the way to the wall one to second
wong on his way to third racing in head
first slide with a triple
ball gets away he's gonna try to score
stumbling in and
shy of home plate and out
trying to make it all the way to the
plate and a smile as he came up about
two inches short
so runners at the corners and it'll
bring in yada yada molina
and yanni sends a sinking liner into
left base hit
and a run will score
that's goldschmidt he comes in to score
and that makes it a three-nothing st
louis lead on the first pitch from clay
holmes three-nothing cardinals
jacob stallings with the bases loaded in
two outs and the oh one pitch by
flaherty
hit the other way base hit sneaks under
the glove of goldschmidt one run in here
comes another
and two run score and the pirates get on
the board and cut the lead to three to
two
paul de young pair strikeouts in a walk
high fly ball deep left field at the
walk on
two run homer paul de young
he strikes late with this two run shot
and the cardinals shortstop has his
first of 2020.
well kk's into the action trying to pick
up his uh
first big league save see if the
pirates can't make it very uncomfortable
let's hit off the glove of the third
baseman and that might go as a hard hit
off of edmond
for josh bell
colin moran singled
last time up bran looked good again
against lefties in spring training and
this is a fair ball down the right field
side
colin moran
well headed to second base with a double
the pirates in business in the ninth
inning so now it's jose osuna with
nobody out representing the tying run
scores one and they're going to wave
home moran and it's a two-run single for
jose osuna it's 5-4
jacob stallings had a huge hit for the
pirates to get them on the board back in
the seventh inning kim is thinking
ground ball double play
ground ball
wong
de young to first cardinals take game
one of the 2020 season and they end it
with a 4-6-3 double play